joining me now for reaction one of the
senators who had a chance to question
judge Cavanaugh today Lindsey Graham
Republican from South Carolina I think
the news cycle took over the
confirmation I think today but the
tactus continued the interruptions
continued I was on radio this morning
hosting my show and it was just one
after the other at where the gallery was
finally cleared yeah you had a gallery I
would have cleared it yesterday to talk
about books somebody should write a book
how not to handle opposition to a person
I was being confirmed for the Supreme
Court the shouting says all you need to
know if you've got something to say you
normally don't need to shout personality
and process is what we're talking about
here tonight regarding person Trump
we're not talking about the results he's
achieved for the American people we're
not talking about Cavanaugh because he's
one of the most qualified people of his
generation you're a lawyer
this guy is brilliant at the end of the
day the book won't matter in 2020 the
article won't matter in 2020 but
Cavanaugh will because people will look
and see what happens if you get a
conservative president you get a
well-qualified limited judicial activist
judge more than 1/8 of the federal bench
has now been appointed by Donald Trump
eat your hearts out yeah and Mitch
McConnell's donor yeah he's a phenomenal
really have Mitch so this this this
Brett's gonna get confirmed he's a court
for the for the first 54 to 56 or figure
he's gonna get confirmed exercise in
futility and I can't wait to see him on
the bench I'm gonna go he's gonna be
here so let's talk though about what
happened with the New York Times yeah so
I want another Network earlier the
allegations in this column I don't want
to call it a column it's it's just it's
a self-serving there it's so easy to
write a positive piece about yourself or
point paint yourself in the best
possible light that's the easy thing to
do what do you think of the overall
point that Oh Donald Trump's just so
impulsive everyone's in there checking
what he's doing thank God there are all
these noble people inside so this person
says that there was an effort to invoke
the 25th amendment that's BS I know
everybody in this administration and
whispers she said whisper it's a clue
Trump Trump be a handful yeah is that
why he won yeah so I'm a handful yeah
that's why you're on TV and you have
your own show so the bottom line
this person says Trump's not serving the
Republic well where I live in South
Carolina people are extremely pleased he
doesn't adhere to conservative
principles everybody I knew at South
Carolina likes the judges like the
military like the tax cut by studi
regulation they like what he's doing
so this person's view of the president
he's serving or she is serving is out of
sync with the people who elected him the
president in a tweet tonight said that
this could be a national security issue
the person should be named and that was
kind of dismissed out of hand but that's
actually an interesting question well
you know is it not been you remember
back in you know the Watergate stuff you
know the Pentagon Papers this is mostly
opinion mr. president if you're watching
here tonight if I were you I would
ignore the article I would ignore the
book and I would tell the American
people what I've done and what I'm going
to do you've got an incredible story for
less than two years of being president
and I think the best is yet to come just
stay on track you will not be affected
by this book or this article what you
will be affected is by the choices you
make and when you pick a cabin owned or
gorsek it's going to help you when you
rebuild the military is broken you're
going to get credit for that when you
take our fight to the enemies unlike
Obama you make us safer so don't just
stop tweeting I told the mate he's
watching well tweet all you want to but
on occasion talk about what you've done
what you have done blows my mind okay
we've been in this thing less than two
years we got two of the greatest pigs of
a generation we have an economy nobody
dreamed of we got a military this
Obama's economy that's what the left a
they tweet Thank You Obama this is the
this is the refrain but no twenty-fifth
amendment a toy whispers you stole BS
complete BS I would know that you
wouldn't well given given your given
your your history given your
understanding your position Senator
Graham thank you so much for coming on
tonight